Speaker 1: All right.
It is time for the Friday mailbag.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com
if you have something you'd like to say.
Ask complaints whatever the case may be.
Also, any time you post on YouTube or reply
to us on Twitter or whatever it might end
up featured in the mailbag, you just never
know.
But let's get into the first one.
Collin wrote in with a beautiful anti-Semitic
conspiracy theory.
Colin wrote in about the Khazar influence
in U.S. politics, saying, David, if you really
had any intelligent intention of being a good
American patriot, please check out your relatives
dealings in U.S. politics.
Obviously, you won't and dare not.
That's Colin.
Now, this is something called the Khazar myth.
This is an anti-Semitic trope.
It has been largely abandoned, although some
really hardcore anti-Semites still talk about
it.
The idea is that Ashkenazi Jews like me, whose
lineage goes to Eastern Europe that are lineage,
is basically fake and that we are really descended
from Khazars who are a multiethnic Turkic
peoples, semi-nomadic and blah, blah, blah.
Basically the idea is even the people we claim
to be is a lie.
This has been extraordinarily widely debunked.
It's nonsense.
Only the most hardcore anti-Semites still
push it.
But that's Colin.
And we do have some of them in our audience,
that's for sure.
Rob wrote in and says, David, sir, the new
haircut looks spectacular when you go to your
stylist.
What exactly do you ask for?
Love the show.
Keep up the good work.
That's Robin, Cincinnati.
Well, listen, Rob, I've been going to the
same hairdresser for over a decade, so at
this point, she says same thing.
Just shorter.
I go, Yep, same thing we've been doing.
And then that's really it.
But if I had to start from scratch, I think
what I would say is I part my hair on this
side.
I want scissors all around.
Nope, nope.
Buzzers are clippers other than for the sideburns
and, you know, the back of my neck and just
kind of this is this is the shape.
Or maybe I would even take a screenshot of
my show and say, this is the haircut I'm looking
for.
I think that's the best advice I can offer.
Alex wrote in about people making guns at
home.
A recent horrible shooting, guns were made
at home.
And Alex says, Hey, David, I just heard your
good point about people making guns at home.
However, this got me thinking about how absurd
this situation is, for example.
Terrorists make their bombs at home.
So should bombs be legal because we can't
stop literally all bomb attacks?
Should theft be legal because we can't stop
all thieves?
Should murder be legal because we can't catch
all murderers?
Mitigation and deterrent are words that exist.
Yeah.
On the entire.
So after the shooting, where the.
I don't even remember which one it was because
there's so many.
Was it the July 4th one where the gun the
guns were made were made at home?
Okay.
You had some people on the right, the pro-gun
people, saying this is why gun control does
nothing.
You can't stop people if they're really determined
from getting guns, they can just make them
at home.
And of course, the reaction is, oh, I'm sorry,
it was the Japanese shooting, the Japanese
shooting, the assassination of former Prime
Minister Shinzo Abe.
And the thing was, you can barely buy guns
in Japan, but they just made them at home.
If in the United States, every would be shooter
and I'm talking about individual homicides,
mass shootings and suicides, if every would
be shooter in the United States could only
get access to a firearm by making it at home.
The number of shootings would go down dramatically.
Dramatically.
I know what you're saying.
Well, but you could make the gun at home.
Yes.
Most people don't know how to do it.
Many who could research it to figure it out
would say, that's too much work.
I don't want to do that.
And the number of people who would be dissuaded
from shooting anyone if they had to make their
gun at home is an incredible number.
And sure, somebody will make their gun at
home.
I understand.
But the whole point, as Alex points out here,
is mitigation and deterrent.
And if you had to make a gun in order to shoot
someone, the number of shootings goes down
dramatically.
Dustin says about my commentary on Jesse Lee
Peterson being homophobic but also being gay.
Dustin says Lethal takedown and all totally
true.
However, you end the clip by saying you're
uncomfortable with Peterson's role as a counselor
to young men.
The implication is your discomfort stems stems
from him being gay.
I don't think this matches your values, and
it's a terrible thing to imply that is not
at all what I meant.
The reason I'm uncomfortable with Jesse Lee
Peterson mentoring young men.
Is because he does this thing that many in
the religious community do, which is they're
not therapists.
They're completely unlicensed to be in that
role.
But they loosely use the term counseling.
Sometimes they use coaching.
That's what I have a problem with.
Not the fact that he's gay and in general,
the type of I mean, listen, he was doing anti-gay
Christian counseling.
I'm against anti-gay Christian counseling,
whether the counselor is gay or straight.
Okay.
So, Dustin, please don't attribute to me things
that I very clearly didn't say.
Eric wrote in and said, Tell the truth, Pacman.
Biden's inflation caused a recession as consumers
tighten their belts.
People react to high prices by cutting back
on food and travel.
This news is nothing to celebrate.
There is no evidence of that.
There's no evidence of that.
If you believe that the COVID stimulus that
Biden did caused inflation, then you've got
to blame Trump doubly because Trump had two
of those packages of stimuli, packages of
stimulus.
I guess it would be.
And also, we're seeing the inflation globally.
So this is just a completely baseless claim.
And there's a lot of them floating around.
People aren't limited by the facts when they
make claims.
Basic Dad says, Why doesn't Packman simply
move to Venezuela?
Where can live in peace and harmony with those
who agree with his socialist viewpoint?
Do you think this person knows a damn thing
about me?
Number one, I'm not a socialist.
Number two, I don't like the Chavez Maduro
regime in Venezuela.
I think they're terrible.
In fact, there's people in my audience who
love the regime and are mad at me that I don't
like it.
I think that it's a disastrous regime that
has eliminated the independence of courts
and in some cases, media that has raped and
pillaged the country's resources for their
gain, not that of its population.
I think that they're horrible.
So maybe someone who likes Venezuela and is
a socialist wants to move there.
But I'm good.
Basic dad.
Thank you, clown wrote in.
Clown says, I'm going to issue a dire warning
to Musk, Pacman and all of Trump's critics
out there.
If you do not want to go to prison or a reeducation
camp, I would refrain from any more criticism
of Donald Trump.
I say this because there's a very good chance
that he can become president again.
And with the way the country is going.
I truly believe Trump is going to be hell
bent on revenge for his enemies.
I know that may sound absolutely insane, but
it is very plausible that something like that
could easily happen if Trump gets back into
the White House.
Anyone who was speaking in a negative way
against Trump, I believe, I believe will be
imprisoned and sent to a camp.
So here's my thought, clown.
I don't deny for a second that Trump would
love to do that if he became president again.
But I don't think he's going to.
I think he will fail to do that.
But your sense of the instincts Trump would
have I can't disagree with.
Last one today is from John.
John says, I see Mr. Pacman playing the victim.
Mr. Pacman trolls every Trump rally, but when
someone trolls him, he has to make a deal
about it.
I wonder why Mr. Pacman didn't troll 2000
miles for only 30 seconds.
Actually, we looked at, like, 15 minutes of
2000 miles.
It's a joke.
2000 miles trolls itself.
I don't even really have to do anything.
John goes on.
Mr. Pacman narrative is getting destroyed
as Americans are more concerned with the inflation
and gas prices and the terrible rise in crime
in mostly all the Democrat run areas, Democrat
run areas.
We've talked about inflation.
Gas prices are coming down quite quickly.
Crime in democratic cities.
Know crime is in cities.
Cities tend to be democratic.
Safe cities are run by Democrats.
Less safe cities are run by Democrats.
It's a very old trope and also important.
By crime rates, the crime rates are often
high in rural and suburban conservative areas.
But narrative rape, that definitely gets in
the way of a good narrative.
Send in your messages info at David Pakman
dot.
They may be used on a future show.
And remember that Tuesday, July 26th at 6
p.m. Eastern is the next David Pakman show
viewer townhall will stream live on Pacman
Live.
Hope to see you there and we'll see you on
today's bonus check.